je m'interrogais le 9 décembre 2022 lors
d'une de mes interventions dans le cadre
de la j de laicité sur le fait qu'on
laisse encore le soin aux chefs
d'établissement de définir si tel ou
telle tenu sont ostensiblement
religieuses ce comportement n'avait pour
effet que de mettre dos à dos ceux qui
les tolèrent les gentils et ceux qui s'y
opposent les méchants les abayas les
Camille même le voile affichent
ostensiblement l'appartenance religieuse
islamique de ceux qui les portent il n'y
a pas besoin de savoir si ces tenue
vestimentairire s'accompagne de discours
ou d'attitude qui contestent la laïcité
et si S d'un comportement prilite ou
communautariste le simple fait de les
porter est un acte de défiance vis-à-vis
de la règle commune il s'agit ni plus ni
moins d'un appel à la désobéissance
civile la règle commune est ce qui donne
la structure à une société sans
structure la société s'écroule je ne
peux que féliciter Monsieur Atal de
rejoindre mes convictions et de prendre
clairement position en renonçant avec la
practique du cas par cas qui prévalait
avant la loi de 2004 il faut arrêter de
croire que ceux qui ne respectent pas la
léicité n'en comprennent pas le sens ils
le comprennent trop bien et c'est pour
cela qu' veulent la détruire le tout ce
n'est pas de parler de chantier comme
l'a martelé monsieur le Président Macron
ce 24 juillet dernier avec des travaux
de rénovation coûteux pour réparer les
défauts visibles négligeant les fils
cachés et bien de définir s'il s'agit
d'un chantier de construction ou de
démolition